welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins it's
a fitness competition show that takes
inspiration from the films of the mcu
and uses them to
get my fellow nerds eric boss and tommy
bechtold into the best shape of their
lives or die trying
which considering this week's opening
film inspiration
is infinity war that just might happen i
gotta confess something here i know i've
said this show was my idea and i'm just
trying to help my friends out
but honestly that's not true well i mean
it's partially true but here's what's
true true there's someone else i'm
trying to appease and
that entity has a very specific need
a need that is also very important in
the world of fitness
let me go ahead and invite my poor poor
clueless subjects on and we'll talk
about how all things should be
perfectly balanced
[Music]
hey guys hey so we're done right this is
now weird okay
shut up eric tommy before you launch
into you're still funny every time bit
about how you're all done with all the
workouts and i appreciate all the
flexing
i know you you don't need any more
fitness i have to tell you
things are actually getting pretty
serious here in this final phase it's
week 10 of your workouts and
guys i've been failing you i haven't
done a good enough job pushing you two
to get it right i think you've done a
pretty good job
i agree with you phillip i think it's
your fault no we're not in better shape
yeah philip you know a better man a
stronger man would have had me in better
shape right now uh but a handsomer man
that's not possible so don't beat
yourself up too much because well you
may not have been pushing me hard enough
you've been looking good if we're just
blaming all of our
health issues on philip that's right
wake up with a cough phillips fault
sneezes at night philip's fault when i
ate uh chipotle for five meals of the
day and then i sat my bed that night
phillips fall you guys are right i i've
i've been terrible but
this week for the love of god
it is so important we're gonna nail it
everything it's gonna be perfectly
balanced in
every way are you having an ocd episode
again
no yes but it's not related this is
about
someone else and they're pissed and so
we're gonna do things right
for once phillip please
just tell me who you want me to seduce
i'm sorry tommy he's
unsedusable that's what they all say
and unfortunately that is usually the
correct
uh response okay great guys no more
messing around
let's talk balance i know that it's been
hard for you guys to nail the macro
ratios i've had you focusing on for the
last 10 weeks but
first messing up on those ratios that's
gonna end
now you're gonna do your 40 carbs
40 protein and 20 healthy fats
all balanced meals all week long i don't
know
i think that's gonna be i'm not done
you're also going to strike a perfect
balance on your caloric intake this
means i need
all of your calories each day that you
consume to fall perfectly inside of the
range
between your rmr and your tde you
haven't taught us these acronyms yet
yeah i don't know what that means
i know that i have ibs can you get rid
of that i'd love for that to be balanced
out
and guys girls keep telling me i have
bde but i don't know what that means is
that a bad thing
it's not hard your rmr is your resting
metabolic rate you just use the classic
harris benedict equation
for men you take 88.362 you add that to
13.397 times your weight in kilograms
you add that
to 4.799 times your height in
centimeters
and you subtract 5.677 times your age in
years
are we supposed to be writing this down
tommy come on yours is two
three nine two point one five and mine
is two one five three point three seven
how did you just do that it was easy
then you'll calculate your tde by
multiplying your rmr by your activity
level so that's 1.2 if
a motionless lump of a person like you
guys used to be
1.375 for mildly active people 1.55 if
you're exercising six or seven days a
week which you two are
1.725 if you go hard with those
exercises and 1.9 if you're a superhuman
okay so wait what was my number again
i'm looking for my rem
my ccr no no your td ee
is 3707 and mine is 3337.
oh thank you computer so if you two can
eat
perfectly between those two numbers
you are guaranteed to burn more calories
than you consume so just stay perfectly
within that harmonious range at all
times all week long
that sounds brutal yeah it sounds pretty
tough to keep all this
is just the food part of the challenge
there's more what else
your workouts i need you to add a
balance element to as many of the
exercises as possible we're gonna
build those stabilizer muscles you've
been ignoring that means going on
one arm or one leg or using a bosu ball
anything you can do to add stability and
balance and then
very important you need to work out your
left and right sides perfectly equally
to maintain that balance
okay this is impossible finally and yeah
i
realize yep as long as there's not any
written homework to this component
i'm fine i need you guys to keep logs
everything you eat how perfectly you hit
your macro ratios your caloric intake
range and how many you do
of each exercise phil i already went to
years of middle school in high school
cumulatively
i'm done doing homework you spent 18
years in just
middle school in high school yes that's
right guys look i just need your help
this week it's way too much for me to
track just by watching your vlogs uh
alone
so you you just gotta help me out here
and maybe if we keep
everything perfectly freaking balanced
we might be spared his wrath
wait who's wrath it's that handsome
devil emergency awesome isn't it
no much worse much more handsome anyway
have fun
oh no week 10 day one
so having to limit my caloric intake to
stay in between my
rmr and my tdee definitely gives me a
different energy level than what i'm
used to
but luckily for day one still able to
get through most of it i'm really
worried about day two though
i don't know how i'm gonna do squats on
a bosu ball or try to do like one-legged
planks
being that meticulous and
detail-oriented is not one of my
strengths
i bought some of these meal prep things
hopefully i can measure stuff out into
those and uh
keep philip happy week 10 could not have
come at a worse time for me
i was trying to do everything one-legged
and this is after i had to kind of delay
things because i got the second
kovid shot so i was feeling that faucey
ouchy a little achy
couldn't really get in the workout that
day but you know today i was feeling
back to pretty much 100
but like 100 doesn't mean anything if
you get 50
of your legs to work with i'm not
feeling good about this week i feel that
sense of impending
doom why we got this extra challenge uh
i'm not gonna be able to pull it off
this week
i'm running late to an appointment the
reason i'm running late is because i had
to measure
every single ingredient of my lunch and
by the time i got done cooking it
it took like 45 minutes and i think
maybe this is how people stay skinny
they just freaking measure everything
and then by the time they cook their
breath
the food is on the board maybe that's
the key maybe this is working actually
maybe this is genius campaign problems i
guess ooh champagne sounds good
how much champagne i'll have to measure
that out
hey guys uh happy friday
oh thank god this week's over i mean i
can only fail so many days of the week
this was a tough one phillip i don't
know i uh i thought i was a perfect
specimen
uh ready to go take on the world and it
turns out i uh
can barely do simple math no uh your you
guys you guys have done great but also
you haven't done that that well
and you could uh you know i mean what if
you
strive to be better despite how good
you've
i i don't guys i'm sorry it's not
entirely your fault
that you weren't able to figure out this
complicated challenge this week
i mean we've really tried it was just
like super
hard and impossible i gave it everything
i could and it was not even close to
enough yeah i know
i guess partially i i or a lot i
take the blame on that look i know i
pushed both of you
too hard to try to get you to achieve
perfection
you upset the balance oh god
and now i am here to correct it
zandos who the hell is sandos
he's the entity we've been trying to
pacify tried and
failed okay he sounds like taezon day
no zondos just chooses to represent
himself as someone who is
the perfect balance between nerd and
coal note his
cool clothes and his epically smooth
chocolatey voice
yet still somehow kind of giving off
nerd vibes too
any similarities to tazonde are purely
coincidental
that's correct and philip molina
you have failed me i asked you to
maintain perfect balance within the cool
to nerd spectrum and you
you give me this hey is one of us cool
i just downloaded tick tock no neither
of you is
cool but that doesn't matter because
your little experiment was going to make
you a pair of feet nerds
and i can't tolerate any more of those
blame philip just one second i told you
that we would make this up to you by
just having a perfectly
balanced week we kind of did that
perfectly balanced i move away from the
mic
to laugh
[Laughter]
you threw out their work-life balance
not to mention
you're sending them mixed messages are
they supposed to be satisfied with how
far they've come
or feel bad and have to do better
yes what's so hard about that you're
not getting it the universe craves nerd
balance
which i myself have perfected perhaps
had you given them astigmatism
correcting lenses and stylish flat caps
that would be perfection
perfection but we're just trying to get
healthy yadda yadda your
nerdfit experiment has corrupted my
balance long enough and it must be
corrected
this is gonna be cool he's gonna dust
one of us
ah pick eric no time to use these
infinity stones to undo the damage
you've already done
and get rid of anyone who considers
themselves a
fit nerd in fitnessy
stones i feel like that's pretty forced
didn't you write this oh
yeah because i was pretty drunk during
that look i also would have named you
tennos if i had time to do it over right
the only thing there's time for now is
some
chocolate pain
and just to be clear i'm all about body
positivity and would never
shame anyone for taking control of their
health in a positive way
however they should choose to do it all
nerds are beautiful as they are
and i want all of us to live long
fulfilling lives
oh
that was really nice that was nice to
hear you saying that but also
pick a lane guys nerds or jocks
anyway zondo's out
hi i like that guy he did it
did what mr boss
i don't feel so good
mr voss is my dad's name
all fit nerds everywhere they're gone
so
[Music]
oh no oh no no
no this is terrible news eric i'm still
here that means there must be some sort
of
oversight or something i'm the anomaly
i'm the one
oh well hey at least we don't have to
work out today
you want to go get some froyo yeah let's
get some froyo maybe chase it with a
little hot chicken
yeah let's dip them wendy's frosty style
okay maybe no froyo so we don't cheat on
our diets
okay however we could so easily with
doordash
so could you right now doordash is
providing you with 25
off your order and zero delivery fees as
long as it's your first order
and for fifteen dollars or more but if
you're ordering less than fifteen
dollars from doordash
you're doing it wrong treat yourself put
some sprinkles on your froyo if you're
gonna get it
that's it just download the doordash app
and use our code
nerd fitness reminder that's 25 off up
to a 10
value and zero delivery fees on your
first order when you download the
doordash
app on the app store and enter our code
nerdfitness ordering from doordash saves
me a ton of time
and hopefully will help me appease
zondos so
use the code nerdfitness and knock 25
off your order
subject to change turn supply
so philip definitely dusted but we're
still doing fitness origins so
where the hell are we and who the hell
brought us here well whoever brought us
here and whoever's gonna be running
fitness origins better have also brought
a
sweet box of cookies because i'm going
to win today and that's going to be my
cheat meal when i punish you
punishment yeah because you've been bad
oh i'm afraid i'll be the only box of
sweets you'll be seeing today
oh that voice yes yes
it is right it is i jess clemens here to
save
fitness origins oh i'm in target heart
rate zone three yeah
first we have to rescue philip and all
the hot buff
fit tasty nerds that dusted away and i
always have a plan so don't worry
however
we need pen particles to make that
happen and since you two
big dumb fools just fought the entire
time at the last ant-man challenge
instead of securing the pym particles i
am gonna have to force you to go in and
get the pin particles for me
since the quantum realm is dangerous you
only have two minutes before i pull you
out
so while you're down there you might see
janet van dyne if you
secure her rescue her and take her out
of there you won the challenge
automatically
there was some confusion about this last
time you want me to seduce her right i
never said seduce
okay i said secure i mean harry potter
seduced that snitch when he kissed it
he did not seduce anything she's the
snitch of this right she's what are you
guys making up things
we're just taking your words no you're
taking it changing them and the
internet's gonna go off on me
okay potato potato yeah i don't like
where this is going there's a thin line
and you guys are crossing it
just get out of here all right
all right we're not playing by the rules
this time here
all right you play by your rules don't
play my mind baby
i want to live down here forever
how many pin particles do we need to
save half of all life
by the end of this i'll became the
conqueror
give me those i want your apples
i think i lost them when i put them
that's what gina gives you eric
[Music]
eric i think you're getting better at
this that's my secret tom
i'm always sticky
[Music]
eric i think the quantum realm is
slimming for you i feel a lot lighter
here
what are the physics of the quantum
realm this makes no sense
i don't know where is janet
there's janet i saw janet i swear to god
i think we're ready out of time
let's beat it
welcome back and congratulations for
tommy obviously pointed the most pin
particles but
janet you left her down there so she's
just doomed forever i guess
she'll be fine she liked it down there
she was happy she was twirling through
the sky
well you did say congratulations usually
there's a little something
maybe about a cheat meal coming our way
yeah a little yummy yummy oh the gmail
neither of you guys are getting the
cheat meal i'm in the cheat meal you
guys are just
making up for your from last time all
right can i eat these let's go eat some
broccoli
happy sunday boys congratulations on
literally doing the bare minimum
to make up for your past mistakes
also oh my gosh i want to thank the
great gods at doordash for my delicious
meal um i believe it's supposed to be a
sweet sweet doordash cheat meal
[Music]
where's our meal this feels almost as
hostile as when philip hosts
okay first off i told you you weren't
getting the meal you may have got the
pin particles
but now there's a lot of ways this can
go and let me tell you they're not good
wait you've seen all 14 million 605
possibilities how many different
characters are you playing
i've seen all the options next week and
let me just tell you
you guys have to do your best next week
the best that you've ever done
or all of the fit nerds will be lost
forever and we don't want that
wait a minute wait a minute and how many
possibilities do we win
yeah anyway how many ways can we have a
good enough week
oh my god only one sure i wasn't really
listening okay
bye you guys bye wait wait wait wait
okay fine i guess we'll split the outro
tommy uh so that's it for this week of
fitness origins but for those of you
watching at home now is a great time to
go subscribe to
epic hero fitness and join us in
starting your own fitness origin
there are five days of workouts already
there pick a day to start and just
jump in show us your photos with the
hashtag fitnessorigin
to be featured on the show here are some
people that have already jumped in with
us
and we'll see you next time on fitness
origins search edition
[Music]
you